if I had to choose a Air Marshal for the
flight that I was on it would definitely
be Liam Neeson I mean come on you can
kill a guy with his pinky finger he's a
Jedi he trained Batman for goodness
sakes there's no better option
[Music]
non-stop stars Liam Neeson as an Air
Marshal on a flight that gets hijacked
it gets hijacked in a different way
though he's receiving text messages from
someone he doesn't know who this person
is he's threatening to kill someone
every 20 minutes and his job is to find
out who this guy is try to save everyone
on this plane will also attempt to not
be framed because this guy is framing
him for the hijacking that I was looking
for this movie because it's Liam Neeson
I mean Liam Neeson is amazing he adds
credibility to just about anything I
mean you could sit down on a bench and
look at a bird and be like Bart come
over here I'm the Air Marshal on this
plane I'm trying to say that where's my
daughter and I totally believe the
entire thing and in this movie he adds
that credibility he definitely does and
it's necessary because this movie is
very implausible at times and I can tell
you one thing a lot of critics are gonna
hate on this movie I think because there
are a lot of elements to it that don't
make sense things don't add up a lot of
things are very convenient when you
discover what is going on how certain
things could have happened and you're
thinking to yourself wow everything just
happened just right and if it hadn't
happened that way this whole movie
wouldn't work and there were elements of
the movie where if you actually think
about it it doesn't really make sense
sometimes there are some impossibilities
but I must say that I was entertained by
this movie I thought it was well acted
and well-directed I was actually into
the characters I cared about Liam
Neeson's character I thought it was an
interesting character he wasn't just
some mindless action hero he actually
felt like a human being for various
reasons and for that reason I latched
onto him as a character I thought he was
great in the movie I was invested in
this movie and I thought it was very
suspenseful and tense I actually really
enjoyed non-stop despite its
implausibility I do think there is a
rare film that happens every once in a
while where if it's directed and acted
and written with enough passion to the
point where you can really tell these
actors and the director care about what
they're doing and are actually trying to
make a very good film and if the film is
on that perfect level of fun where it
doesn't try to be overly serious in all
of their wrong ways but it has the
serious dramatic
that you need to create a good character
and make you care about the rest of the
people in the movie if all of those
things fall into place a movie that is
endlessly implausible and doesn't always
make sense I think can be good and
non-stop I think is that movie I was
really interested in the mystery and
that's one of the things I gotta say
about this movie even though there were
times where I was like I gotta figure it
out
it took a left turn that surprised me
and yes part of that is because a lot of
it is implausible and sometimes you're
like wow that doesn't really make sense
I don't know if it would happen that way
but at the same time am i a freaking air
pilot marshal expert man of everything
no I'm not there are things in this
movie where I'm like yeah no but I
enjoyed it I can't deny the fact that I
enjoyed this movie I thought Liam Neeson
was great in the movie this comes from
the director of unknown another Liam
Neeson movie that came out in February
and he makes a very sleek looking movie
here the shots are well done
there isn't any overtly obvious horrible
camerawork it actually looks really nice
and the fact the whole movies on this
plane also makes it very claustrophobic
and he felt very contained and I really
like suspenseful movies like that where
it takes place all in one location
because you really start to feel as if
you are there and I thought it worked
I'm surprised non-stop was a very
enjoyable movie for me I thought Liam
Neeson was great in the movie Julianne
Moore also provided some really good
supporting work I had fun with this
movie I thought it was a suspenseful
movie I thought it was well done there
are some plot contrivance 'iz and some
implausibility up the butt but I had fun
with it I'm gonna give non-stop a B+ so
guys if you saw the movie what'd you
think of it do you agree with me that
there is that one movie that comes along
every once in a while that can be
over-the-top that can be unrealistic but
if it's done on that right level you can
have fun with it and I think non-stop is
that movie guys thanks so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck with
niced
[Music]